[Music]
well the growing concern now over drugs
that are laced with fentanyl has so many
parents wondering what they can do to
prevent their own children from finding
these dealers online if i take this pill
am i going to die metro police want
teens asking that as more pills tainted
with fentanyl are being sold to kids
online a lot of our dealers are using
these different
web platforms or social media platforms
to get on and
and to sell their sell their drugs local
law enforcement can shut down websites
but it takes time these criminals you
know if we shut down their operations or
shut down their web page they're usually
back up and running with a new website
you know within hours kids think they're
getting a party drug or painkiller but
it's actually the highly dangerous and
potent synthetic opioid fentanyl a
granule a salt granule is enough to kill
you it just shuts your body down you can
within minutes to hours you could be
dead fentanyl is inexpensive and
extremely lethal it's being mixed into
other drugs often without the buyer's
knowledge to any parent watching the
experts say the time to talk to your
teen about this is today what i really
want a parent to do is have the
conversation have the conversation one
pill can kill and after this crucial
talk tangible technological steps can be
taken you can actually create a child
icloud account that's kind of a sub
account of your own and then you can set
parental permissions on that you can
whitelist the websites they like and
that will really prevent them from
getting onto websites where they could
be ordering things that you know could
end up being life ending according to
the cdc there were nearly a hundred and
eight thousand drug fatalities in the
u.s last year
one pill can kill the access to any
narcotics or drugs is obviously a huge
concern to us at the police department
and should be a huge concern to parents
so parents a great time to talk with
your kids about these risks online
additional safety tips can be found
under the cyber safe parents tab over on
eight newsnow dot com